my question is about abortion
so usually when i talk about that with
other you know folks
either the approach is
from a relation religious standpoint or
trying to apply science to it
so but never seen like a
kind of like a you know happy medium
between the two so are you optimistic
that there's gonna be i don't know
a resolution to that issue that up to
that approach maybe from a religious
perspective also with some times in it
um so i i think that the possibility of
a resolution uh is going to be more
incremental than anything else and it's
happening in real time right you can see
the american people's opinions on
abortion have shifted pretty markedly
toward the pro-life position now to get
all the way to the full pro-life
position that i hold which essentially
is that from conception this is when
life begins it's going to take more work
it's going to take more education and
it's going to take a ground shift in the
way that americans tend to think about
these issues but as people see with more
clarity into the womb itself as people
see the biology more clearly they're
beginning to to become less and less
warm toward abortion like the actual
number of abortions in the united states
has dropped now to its lowest levels
since actually roe v wade and that is in
large part due
that's in large part due to the
educational efforts of a wide variety of
groups it's due to 40 ultrasounds it's
roots of the ability it's due to the
ability to see more of the human biology
and as people understand biology better
they're going to be more pro-life